me fat fat people raise fat children
because they passed you you pass your
ways you know but sometimes the parents
that's why rich people typically their
children are also Rich because they pass
on the knowledge of being but sometimes
I know families I know families where
the parents are like twigs and the kids
are like Monsters I literally and I
don't mean that in a bad way but
compared to the parents
this is an open invite look at anybody
that thinks they cannot lose weight for
whatever reason it's impossible okay
I'll pay for it come come to London eat
the client come on down you need to be
careful what you say because there might
be a lot of big people that start
messaging you